c'est publiquement les agissements d'un
prêtre en adressant un coup il ya
l'évêque du diocèse
l'affairé a pris une tournure que je ne
comprends pas trop si un peu caché je
sais pas cet homme a aussi dénoncé les
agissements du prêtre de sa paroisse en
guyane des démarches effectuées auprès
des autorités civiles mais aussi
religieuse face au manque de réactivité
il est venu en martinique afin de
rencontrer la délégation de la sias pour
lui il y a urgence le cul est toujours
en place malgré certains éléments qui
ont été recueillies contre lui donc je
ne comprends pas pourquoi il est
toujours en place peut-être que c'est un
cas
un peu particulier que le dieu serpent
encore affronter et les choses se
mettent en place lentement comme on dit
les enquêteurs
c'est une affaire sensible donc il faut
le temps le temps d'enquêter il faut
surtout pas faire les choses
précipitamment mais ce que je ce que je
peux dire c'est que notre église souffre
notre église se meurt à saint laurent du
maroni et on a envie qu'elle brille à
nouveau oui martinique guadeloupe et
guyane sont et ont été confrontés aux
actes pédophiles mine elle exercé par
des membres de l'église
mais ici plus qu'ailleurs il est
difficile de briser la loi du silence
c'est très difficile de pouvoir parler
d'une agression qui a été commise par un
membre de l'église dans un environnement
où la présence de l'église est très
importante et de ce fait là le respect
qui lui est donnée par sa présence et
par sa force risque d'écraser la
personne qui se sent tout petit par
rapport à une institution aussi
importante pour les membres de la sias
il faut donc travailler le lien de
confiance
nous avons mis en place pour les
victimes qui le souhaitaient des
entretiens individuels avec demande de
la cciad il n'y en a eu 150 et si
l'entretien sont totalement anonymes
c'est à dire qu'à tout moment la victime
reste maître de son témoignage est
choisie coupant de là qu'elle soit
diffusée sur le site internet de la sias
et pour ceux qui souhaitent plus de
confidentialité
les témoignages peuvent être effectués
par mail par courrier ou par téléphone